so today we're going to be looking at
something called random boolean networks
and branding boolean networks were
created to try and understand
the complexities of biological systems
so biological systems cells do lots of
very complicated things
um and the the random boolean network
was a demonstrate a demonstration to try
and understand
whether these complicated behaviors
could arise from actually very simple
rules
so the random boolean network is a
computational model
built up a very simple rules to see that
if out can
out of these simple rules very complex
behavior
emerge this reminds me a little bit of
conway's game of life which we've we've
briefly discussed
on the channel is it something similar
to that or is it is this the same
yeah no so it's um it's a little bit
different but it isn't it is very
similar so a random boolean network
consists of a set of nodes and the way
these nodes change over time
they have specific rules which are a
little bit like conway's game of life
um so yeah not not too dissimilar how'd
it work then where do you start with one
of these
a random booty network can be described
as
a set of 20 nodes each of which has a
boolean state attached to it
and for any given node its boolean state
is determined
by connections to other nodes within the
network
so each node's behavior is determined by
the other nodes in the network like a
complex interacting system so before we
get the comments about
drinking game drink every time he says
boolean when we're saying that we're
talking about a true
or a false or a one or a zero are we
exactly that yeah
so boolean values um either or off or
ones and zeros we're going to be using
ones and zeros in this work
what you can think of is that you can
have 20 nodes to start with
all of them exist within one column to
start with and each of these nodes
within network
has connections to other nodes this is
how you initialize network and we're
just going to say that each node within
the network
is connected to three other nodes you
then get the values
of the nodes in which it's connected to
and because we've only got three
connections
we're going to get three boolean values
out of that
so something like zero zero one one one
one zero one something like that and
then what we do
is we build a truth table we've got
eight different options so essentially
counting from zero to seven
in binary that's in one column of the
truth table in the other column
we then randomly assign a result to this
and we only do this once at the start of
the program
so that if a given node
has connections which give it the values
one zero one that node will then change
its state to zero
if it has connections that give it zero
zero one
then that node will change its value to
one
and we do this all at the same time and
then once this is completed we then get
a new set
of 20 boolean states for our nodes and
then we can repeat this over successive
iterations
and get this behavior as time moves on
over successive time steps
so we'll get these 20 nodes each of
which has a state one or zero
and then each one is being fed by
three or you know up to three of the
other nodes and then you get the next
step and then exactly
that's right yep that's how it's done um
so yes not not not terribly complicated
simple rules um
boolean values everywhere um they
randomly start
they randomly start with randomly
assigned boolean variables
the truth tables got random boolean
variables in it so you would expect it
just to be a bit of a mess
but it does show some some very
interesting behavior i've programmed
this
um to show you so i can actually show
you the output
from from the program and i've got a few
um
a few different examples of this so when
you first start with a random booty
network and everything's
random as the name suggests you'd expect
it the output just to be a bit of a mess
and sometimes that's exactly what it is
so if i just load up
an example here so just to explain this
in the way that i've coded it a zero is
represented as a zero
so that's false and a one is represented
as a space
and that just makes it easier to see the
patterns within the network and this is
pretty much what you'd expect from such
a system at the start because it's a bit
random
you get surrounding behavior which you
see here and then everything would
just peter towards some steady boring
state which is what we've got here which
is
um some nodes in the network being
permanently off but some of them
switching between
ons and officers time goes by so this is
exactly what you'd expect
and there are a few examples of this and
this is an example of a network where
everything just turns on
forever so this is actually what i would
expect to happen from a network which
was built in this way
however we could also get these cycles
that appear
and again the networks start off and
they've got some some random noise here
they're not doing too much
but they fall into this cyclical
repeating pattern which is quite
interesting for something that's so
so random i wouldn't have expected this
um this type of behavior to happen but
it actually happens
relatively frequently and there are
different examples of this that we can
see
so all of which start off as i say in a
bit of a random state but they
tend towards some nice nice regular
patterns
this is a nice property of the network
but i don't think it's particularly
amazing as of yet but there are some
some
other properties that networks have um
as well so one of the things that we've
seen seen here is that these patterns
are they're quite obviously repeating
but the networks also demonstrate so
even with this pattern this is quite a
complicated one but if you look at the
spaces
here these squares here and this shape
you can see this pattern repeating
so even though this is quite complex
this is still a repeating a repeating
pattern
but we can also get behaviors that
because all behaviors in around
boolean network ultimately will repeat
in the end we can also get ones which
have longer cycles
and they're so long that we actually
can't see the behavior we can't see the
repeating pattern here there will be a
repeating pattern but it's too long to
fit on the screen
and there are a few examples of this
just where we get something which we
can't quite
understand that one looks like it's got
a bit of repeating pattern there but
no we can't see the repeating cycle
so just that's all that's all i suppose
mildly interesting in that you have
you have different behaviors that you
can get from differently randomly
initialized states of the network
okay one of the most interesting
properties of this is when we were
looking at the biological systems which
i i suppose this network was supposed to
naively um emulate
um biological systems are very robust
so cells and things like that they can
actually deal with quite a lot before
they um before they start um
start having problems and one of the
ideas that you can look at with these
networks is can we
inject uh perturbation into this network
and and see how um it responds over
over time we can do exactly that what's
perturbation
then is that just to change is that
fancy word for changing it that's
exactly what it is so what we're
actually going to do
is about halfway through um
the network operating we are going to go
through five
nodes of the network and just change
their bits so we're gonna if it's a one
we're gonna flip it to zero and if it's
a zero we're gonna flip it to a one
and we're just gonna see what happens
after that again one of the things that
you'd expect to see here
is that the networks just change what
they're doing
and continue in this new state
for the rest of time and sometimes
that's exactly what happened this
perturbation injected here and you can
see that the repeating pattern changes
so we have a bit of a mess down here and
then
the network just changed into a
different
but other cyclical state and there are a
few examples of this
again of just one state transforming
into another because of this
perturbation but still
maintaining its regularity but it's a
different kind of regularity
it sort of reminds me of gene mutations
yep so it was exactly that so the idea
that if you have a simple organism and
can mutate genes if other genes are
applied
are relying on the products of those
genes
then you can have um changes within the
biological system does something else
need to come in
to take over what was caused by that
perturbation
um and that that was exactly the point
of these networks is to try and show
that
um you know robustness specifically
although we're not demonstrating
robustness right now
where buses can come out of very very
simple
um simple networks with very simple
rules so there is a chance that
barge itself might be underpinned by
such rules which are indeed as simple we
just don't know what they are yet
so yeah these are so when we inject the
perturbations here we can see the
networks change over time but go into a
different type of regular behavior
however there's a few networks where we
inject the perturbation here
and then the network recovers from that
perturbation to be exactly where it was
and i think this is the behavior that
people are most interested in because i
think this most captures
um sort of the the principle of
robustness and biology that things have
to accept perturbations and go back to
what they're doing
and we have to point out here that there
is a chance because this network doesn't
really change too much
there's a little bit of a change we can
see because we've got these four
repeating zeros
and it changes to three there but then
goes back to four but
it's it could be possible in this
network there's just not too many
connections
to the these five nodes so if we change
them it might not have that much of an
effect on the network
so that's possible so let's look at a
few more examples
this is another example where we have um
a change the repeating pattern that you
can probably see by looking at the top
we've got this bit of confusion here
which isn't seen before
but then it goes back into the repeating
pattern that it had before so we
gave it this perturbation it doesn't
seem to be too affected by it
so that basically the no all the nodes
are is they just hold a boolean state
so all i'm doing is i'm going in and i'm
just flicking that boolean state over
um which will affect so um
for all genes that are connected to uh
sorry all nodes that are connected to
either one of these five nodes um that
will affect how they interact with the
truth table
that we showed so they might get a
different result there but even even
with that change
we can see that they go back to the same
repeating behavior they had before
so i think one of the most interesting
examples i can show that i found just
from randomly searching these networks
is after we um put the perturbation in
this network
a lot of the network changes so there's
a lot of changes down here there's a lot
of changes here and here as well
but only after about 10 time steps of
what is
a relatively significant perturbation
for a network that's only got 20 nodes
we're switching five of them it goes
back into this regular state
which is something that's quite
unexpected for such a such a simply
constructed network to have this
behavior
and as i said i think this this is sort
of a
visual description of the behavior that
i think stuart calvin was looking for
when he created these models
is to try and show well actually no lots
of
interacting units which have very simple
behavior can
out of which can emerge very complex
behavior which
can underpin lots of the natural
phenomena that we see in the natural
world
so i think yeah i think this is a nice
description of exactly what um
sugar cabin was trying to show with
these and this idea that you can perturb
the networks and they can
ultimately recover to doing doing what
they were doing before
you only have to work out whether it's
worth alerting the user
if you find the key so you know you
download the temporary exposure key you
perform
the encryption you generate the
potential rpis and you compare them with
the ones you see
fill the bergen with the most value
without going over a specified weight
limit